we're gonna go right to the phones um
we're gonna talk to
john in seattle john how we doing
honestly i'm tired man but i'm good oh
man i'm so grateful so
so listen before we get going i want to
talk directly to the audience here and
kind of let you know
about my conversation coming up here
with john
the reality is john and i have already
recorded a conversation together and it
went about 20 minutes or so maybe a
little bit longer and the short of it is
i messed up the call i didn't do a good
job responding
i was wordy and verbose and most
importantly
i didn't pay attention to a couple of
key things and so i
used wrong language i used wrong terms
and i stumbled through
just my response was just poor right and
one of the reasons that i wanted to
talk to john again is what he has what
is going on in his life is important
but two i want to let everyone listening
to this show no
coaches aren't perfect mentors aren't
perfect counselors aren't perfect
the people in your life that you entrust
your heart with your advice to
man they stumble and they mess up and so
i wanted to go first in this
exchange here and let everybody listen
to the show john let you know man i'm
sorry
i didn't do a good job the first time
around still getting used to this show
how everything works
and your situation was unique for me man
and
i want to let everybody know that it's
okay to give somebody else another shot
so john i'm really grateful for you
calling back
and letting me have a mulligan on this
one brother
no i appreciate it and uh listen uh yeah
i'm
a big fan of yours i respect what you do
um and i value your opinion and i
and i realize myself that i i do need a
little bit of help
and uh you know i i appreciate it and
i'm
i'm thankful for getting another shot to
talk to you well thank you so much so
let's
let's walk you back to the beginning
what's going on your life and how can i
help
yeah so um you know i'm in my late 40s
i like to consider myself a success uh i
have a very well-paying job thankfully
and i work a lot of hours like i did
yesterday about 16.
uh providing yeah i know and that's
every other day or so um and
but i uh i struggle uh for a long time
now
uh with an addiction to you know i guess
what i like to call webcam models
uh talking to a woman online
uh you know only online and just talking
erotically to them
uh you know
uh that's that's my addiction and i
spend a lot of money doing it
tell me about the money you've spent
tell me how much time talking about the
the what this is costing you
uh well i mean financially i mean tens
of thousands of dollars
um probably a year at least um
and that's probably being kind and
uh time i just find myself you know and
then
you know instead of reading a book or
working on a novel i
should be writing or something uh
you know i'm on the internet uh just
looking around on these websites for
probably a connection
and interaction um you know that only
lasts
you know 10 or 15 minutes um
but you know before you know it three
hours has gone by you know
and it's it's it's a time suck right and
so
for those listening um webcam girls
are really people on demand right so
they'll
they'll
come into your internet in your house or
if you put on your big screen tv they'll
come in
and you can ex talk with them you pay by
the minute right
was it three to five three to six bucks
a minute something like that
and they'll basically do whatever you
ask them to do
over five minutes 10 minutes two hours
is that am i
am i right there you're 100
right and the interesting thing it's
like in today's world of the internet
it's it's not just like it's actually
you know people would be surprised i
think by who these webcam models are
you know these are normal women who have
had regular jobs and now because of
cobin or whatever
they needed to make an extra income from
their home
you know they're single mothers they're
real people
which i think is what also makes it so
enticing you know
sure um you know so
you do feel like you have some type of
real connection to them
which i lack you know their job
their job is to make you feel connected
right like they're actresses their job
is to make you feel
loved appreciated and more importantly
to keep you on the line as long as
possible because every minute is a is
another cha-ching cha-ching is that
right
uh overall yes you know uh i don't i
don't think they all
you know are you you know they're real
they realize you you know you got to go
you got to do things
but um but um that's what i'm saying to
just real people
which i think is what also makes it so
enticing you know it's not
it's not necessarily just a fantasy girl
you know that is completely unattainable
if that makes sense yeah absolutely so
last time we talked
we dug in a little bit to your past and
just to
for the sake of the time you don't come
from
a home of abuse you've got good parents
you've got a great job
you are somebody that your community
counts on and
is always with you when you step back
30 000 feet and you say i've got this
behavior that is costing me money it's
costing me time
where do you think this comes from what
are you hiding from
what vulnerability are you protecting
yourself from
getting hurt
yeah um you know that's a good question
you know it's um
i don't know you know it definitely
comes from
you know a long long time ago you know
uh
i used to read erotica um
and like that's when i was like in
college somehow i started reading
erotica
and as with a lot of addictions you know
the erotica you know becomes a more
heightened sense of erotica and that you
know when
things progressed you know it became
just calling
you know somebody on the phone you know
before the whole
you know webcaming the old the old 1 900
numbers back in the day right
yeah and then that turned into oh you
could actually
see somebody um
so it goes back quite a long time well
over 20 years
um so what happened now that makes you
want to stop
doing this behavior
well a lot of it you know is financial
you know and yes i do make a good living
but i recognize
how much money i'm spending and i have
for a while and i don't know
like maybe because i'm so close to being
debt-free
you know following you know your boss
dave ramsey as you alluded to last week
um it really bothers me how much money i
am
you know i say wasting but wasting
you know and i have been in
relationships where i don't do it
you know i don't have the compulsion to
call
if i am in a relationship but i am not
often in a relationship
you know and that's probably a whole
other issue like
why can't i fall in love and be that
right person right
um but what i do look for somebody
you know and this is the other reason i
think it inhibits
how i think of that person like
initially like i want to know oh are
they open-minded
are they you know for lack of a better
word kiki okay you know
and and i think that's not healthy
so one of the things that stuck in my
head the last time we talked and have
just kind of
bounced around like a bouncy ball in
there for the last
couple of days has been this idea
that i don't know or i haven't been
convinced by you john that
you want to stop this behavior or this
interaction
i understand that you don't like the
derivative effects you don't like a
smaller bank account
you don't like that it when you meet
somebody new your head immediately goes
to
i wonder how bizarre this person would
be or how
different this person would be or to not
use
normed words right i wonder if this
person shares my same
uh sexual identity i wonder if this
person is into the same things i'm into
and you miss the the human exchange
right just the high how are yous
and just the joys and ups and downs and
sadnesses
of just getting to know somebody i
didn't get a sense that that's something
you want to
stop webcam girls you just want these
other things
do you really want to quit this behavior
or
do you just want to be debt free and
have a good relationship
and i hope you can see the difference of
my question there
yeah i mean i think there's a happy you
know yeah that's a good question
um i think there's a happy medium in a
way
you know i mean listen if i'm in a
relationship i do not feel
that i need
you know these women you know on the
internet
um but you know i do
feel or i've convinced myself that they
are giving me something
you know with you know decreasing my
anxiety before work or
um i do feel sometimes
it's you know necessary
um you know or i justify well i'm single
so it's okay
um so make mo make no mistake man they
are giving you something they are giving
you
release they are giving you connection
however broken
and crooked it is it's still connection
right it's still intimacy
and not true vulnerable human to human
intimacy but it is an intimate exchange
especially as you mentioned these aren't
models these aren't professionals these
are
run-of-the-mill folks normal folks from
our neighborhoods right trying to make
some extra money
they are giving you an opportunity to
escape
they are giving you an opportunity to
not live in the reality that you're
lonely
not live in the reality that for 20
years you've wanted this thing
and not living the reality that
life is filled with complexion and
frustration and real relationships take
a lot of work and they are hard and
they're uncomfortable
they do give you all those things right
and so what
when you're coming up against an
addiction there's got to be a moment
when you say the pain
of continuing this addiction is
i want that gone more than the benefit
i'm getting from it and
and to be honest with you man i don't
hear that from you yet
i hear an annoyance and a frustration
not a
face in the dirt i have to be done with
this
and for a 20-year addiction i think
that's where you've got to be i think
you can't casually
or sort of or happy medium your way
out of this situation or you got to find
somebody who's going to be a partner
with you that's going to be
into it too when that's that's a whole
other phone call right
but it doesn't sound like you're at a
place where i just i'm i've got to be
finished with this
am i wrong there um
i don't know that's a good question
that's a good question i don't keep
saying that but
it's um i think by reaching out to you
and putting you know this to air to
whoever hears it
i'm pretty close to that okay um you
know i feel very vulnerable
yeah uh i mean uh pardon me
far to be wanted to call also because i
appreciate all the people who call about
other things
that a lot of people don't talk about
and
uh i know i know a lot of people have
this type of thing
and i thought it was important also for
them to hear
who hears this you know about you know
this type of addiction but
um i do feel
you're you're right i mean because i
deal with alcoholics and i i haven't hit
rock bottom
you know in that way and uh
you know i think because i do make a
good living
it's almost in a way preventing me from
hitting rock bottom
because i haven't lost you know
my family my home alienated you know
personal relationships in my life
and that's a common challenge with
functional recreational drug users right
as it begins to slowly take over
everything
if you are excellent at your job you do
make a good living you can buy yourself
years of punting that challenge down the
road before it comes and gets you right
um so here's the thing i want to address
a couple of things and i even brought
some notes this time um
i think it's important for everyone
listening to this
an addiction to webcam girls an
addiction to
what i would call a sexualized addiction
where you are
numbing the challenges and the
frustrations and the fears of real
relationships and you're trading that
for
um really i guess the old joke is the
oldest job on planet earth right which
is
sex in exchange for money
i want everyone to hear that that's
sensationalized right
this is a real challenge in a real
person's life but most of us
don't walk through our lives struggling
with an addiction to webcam girls
but i don't want a listener to this
podcast to give themself a pass
on the idea that addiction is addiction
is addiction as a culture
if you look at what's happening in covid
we are drinking too much
we are drink i heard 300 times alcohol
sales are up
working too much is is an addiction
sexual infidelity
purchasing things buying things just
getting that quick dopamine hit
when you click through amazon working
out too much
being addicted to measuring your macros
and micros on your
this as a culture we will do anything
to not feel the pain and frustration
and exhaustion of just everyday living
and so while john why your thing is out
there right it's sensationalized and
it's webcam girls
and millions of people listening to this
are going to go
whoa i don't even know that exists or
i've never even heard of that or i just
read about that once
i don't want people to give themselves a
pass right so addiction as addiction is
addiction
the second thing is i if you actually
want to
want to solve this problem right and
again i'm not
super convinced that you're fully in
there john but if you do
i want you to do two things number one i
want you to pick up
a book by gabor mate called in the realm
of hungry ghosts
it's the single greatest book on
addiction i've ever read
i know there's probably a million other
ones but it's a book that really spoke
to me
as an author gabor dr mate speaks to my
heart in several ways but
it's a book on addiction and it walks
through
the the the path that people take to get
where they are
i also want you to pick up a book by
terence real called i don't want to talk
about it
it's the secret legacy of male
depression and folks men especially who
get
wrapped up in sexualized addictions or
addictions of power or addictions of
disconnection
they just go off into another place and
then you find yourself out in the woods
somewhere and you don't know the path to
get back
so those are two important books i also
want to just i can't say this strongly
enough
you cannot get through addiction you
cannot
change your life behavior particularly
one of 20 years
by yourself you're gonna have to get
into
a sexaholics anonymous group you're
gonna have to get into
a 12-step group of some sort you're
going to have to get with a local church
or a local community group you're going
to have to get to some group
and i'm going to recommend if your
addiction is on the internet
if your addiction is online that that's
not a good place to find community and i
know that stinks especially now in covet
man that just sucks but
going online logging in that whole thing
is going to kick in a trigger and that's
going to start the compulsion process
dr mate in his book he talks about five
quick things and i'll run through him
real quick
he talks about when you have these urges
remember that this is not a broken brain
you don't have a disease you've got a
disordered brain a malfunctioning brain
that is trying to compensate for
a lack of stability a lack of
vulnerable relationships a lack of
identity right
and so what you're trying to do when you
when you change your
thoughts and your actions out of an
addictive behavior
you're really trying to heal and
transform a malfunctioning brain he says
so here's the five steps he gives you
number one you have to re-label
thoughts and urges right you don't need
to eat that junk or withdraw
but you've got to stop yourself as these
urges come right
you may have a feeling this urgency you
know john talks about this
this feeling of urgency this compulsion
but there's actually nothing
urgent going on and so you have to
relabel those those
feelings as things i have to do to
okay now i've got to ask myself a hard
question what's my
brain trying to protect me from is it
the stress of going to this busy job
that john has is it this this
frustration this i need to get this
release before i go to work so i can be
calm
it's this impending anxiety
whatever this this feeling this
compulsion is number two you have to
re-attribute it to something else right
you've got to reattribute it towards
from these things that happen to you or
this bad behavior or here comes my
compulsion again i'm feeling myself
want to log in stop stop
dumping a bunch of garbage onto those
thoughts and just re-attribute them to
man what's my brain trying to protect me
from anytime you're about to buy
something
smoke something drink something text
that old girlfriend
anytime you are about to go back to the
gym for a second time
ask yourself what is my brain trying to
protect me from
and then you can even get to a place
through mindfulness where you think your
brain
you say thanks brain i appreciate you
taking care of me the third thing is you
gotta refocus and i know this sounds
cheesy or lame
but you have to decide in that moment
when you feel that compulsion and you
relabel it to
thanks brain for taking care of me you
have to then choose to
go do something else that's in 12-step
programs you call
your sponsor in weight loss programs
you go outside of your home and you go
for a walk
right um whatever it may be is you are
starting to
refocus and teach your brain that it
doesn't have to obey
as dr mate says it doesn't have to obey
the urgency call
the fourth thing is is you have to
revalue
and he suggests it's called devalue
right
but this is just to really drive into
your head
that the real impact of this urge
is disaster it is
tens of thousands the last time john and
i talked
about a hundred thousand dollars he
spent on webcam girls
at some point somebody at work is gonna
find out
somebody's gonna release the footage of
the webcams
somebody's gonna put something out there
somebody's gonna look at your receipts
and see just how much you've been
drinking or you're going to miss a ball
game or you're going to drive drunk or
any number of things that are on the
back of addictive behaviors
you've got to re-value it and understand
that
this only leads to disaster it's going
to feel good right now it's gonna give
me release
this ends in a train wreck and then
you've got to recreate this is the final
one
you've got values you've got passions
you've got talents capabilities he says
but you have to recreate you've got to
recreate
new relationships new default settings
new behaviors
and that ultimately your brain will
begin to when it instead of feeling that
compulsion to
log into a webcam girl to go have
something to drink to get on amazon and
buy something to just sit in front of
netflix and mindlessly scroll
it will say we need to go for a walk we
need to go
hug my wife i've got to take my kids and
go hold both with their hands and we're
going to go out into the woods in the
rain
whatever it is but your brain will
recreate new paths
that you can follow so again i want to i
want to thank john for
number one for giving me a mulligan on
this one i want to thank him for being
vulnerable
and take taking something out of the
darkness that people struggle with
whether it's pornography whether it's
sexual addiction infidelity whatever it
is
webcam girls and broadly
announcing to the world hey i struggle
with this and i've been struggling for a
couple of decades
i also want to encourage john and
everybody listening
find people in your life that you can be
vulnerable and open with
that's the only path to true recovery
from addiction
and then check out dr mate's book these
five values are in that book
and it was a transformative experience
for me reading that book it looks at
how we treat addicts in this culture how
criminalization it talks about all of it
right so it's a good place for you to
start so
um we took a little bit longer with that
call and with this idea of addiction so
again i want to thank john